Guan Takara is a small village on the
outskirts of Nia's capital people here
were born into slavery so most are
illiterate Mohammed moga's also comes
from a family of bonded slaves with Tim
a'dreea he seeks to end the bondage
system through education including an
explanation of basic human rights he's
also helped to build schools slavery is
outlawed in new year but still widely
practiced Apple illusion see if L parte
young people are the decision makers of
tomorrow when they study don't know
their rights which they can then demand
including the rights of their parents
I'm a romantic iliad rattler para about
60 children attend school here the
teacher moved from the capital neomi to
the village when the school opened seven
years ago twelve-year-old sharifa is one
of the most studious pupils in wishing
she says she'd like to learn to read and
write and later work as a nurse in the
air some children are born into slavery
as bonded servants and they're deprived
of all rights they're not allowed to own
any property as slaves they are
considered the property of slaveholders
who object to Timmy trias initiative
this school has been burned down twice
but teaching continues in makeshift
Hut's the children learn reading writing
and arithmetic with enthusiasm some of
the children work their way to secondary
school one day they may be able to free
their families from bonded labor there's
a fault where your deed as I wonders are
funky some of the children have reached
high school level one of them is going
to take final exams closet if he
succeeds he can go to university in the
army dance there'll be a role model for
his village khadijah mo le creo [ __ ]
soca mattila through to me Draya a
non-governmental organization Mohammed
and his assistants have built 28 schools
in rural me share it was hard work at
first they were threatened by
slaveholders and harassed by state
authorities
Astrid a likkle illustrative clr station
Deep Ecology material demi-sec one
example from 2005 was the arrest of some
members of team Adria and for all
Maureen girls while we were organizing
an event in one of the villages a forum
on the freeing of slaves the state
interfered and stopped us yeah method
food the teachers and all of us from Tim
a'dreea were arrested on the pretext
that there is no slavery in Nigeria from
Qantas clavata step out when you shut
despite such intimidation Demetrius
Mission Continues children like sharifa
are making progress at school while
helping out at home when she grows older
she may be able to decide her own
destiny
you